you know for people who don't know man
like dolph's been kind of
obviously before his passing he was so
passionate about like putting on people
from his city yeah you know what i'm
saying like that was like one of his
major
um
missions um with with paper rock empire
um what was uh what was it about you
that got him on
or got you on his radar rather
and a lot when i was like when i was
young
you know we from the sign area so mm-hmm
that was like
i'm coming up that was the reasoning in
the hood like coming through and
porsches and all the you know what i'm
saying whips big boy giant big boy rings
like yeah
i want to do what he's doing right there
he turned
so but what what um what were you doing
that caught his attention
yeah to sign you yeah oh yeah i was
doing it i was making my way towards
what he was doing you know i was
shooting my own videos
booking my own shows just turning up
just turning up doing it dropping music
going crazy yeah and it and it obviously
caught his attention yeah and i used to
call him for like advice i was scared i
want to know so i'm trying to hit you up
hey bro what this mean what
how much this cause what i need to do
with this like not even sign he was
still giving me all the game he was
giving me so before you even signed him
you had you were able to reach out to
him and get game from him for sure what
do you think like uh is some of the best
advice you ever got from dolph
my
bsl
like be yourself and keep working the
work going to talk for you you ain't got
to say much just work everything on show
nah for sure man um
work ethic is i think what does it mean
like we see a lot of people who were
like man a lot of cats ain't even as
talented as some of the people we know
but it's the workout
like don't never let nobody out work you
that's all he's telling me just work
hard 100 man um so you finally got your
tapes coming out at midnight i'll take
on that midnight um the long long lived
off project came out which was a a great
body of work great dedication to the
homie yeah i put my we put my my whole
tape my table was supposed to drop
like in november but
of course long the dog had to come out
you know what i'm saying yeah like great
tape shout out emily choppa2 he moved
his release date back a week for that
project um yeah
yeah um